camera thrower gwenberry sparking
furious uproar for turning her back on
the american flag
during a medal ceremony at the u.s track
and field trials she then covered her
head with a t-shirt that said
activist athlete barry claims organizers
should have played it before she got on
the podium
and that she was the victim of a setup
she says the anthem does not speak for
her
and that she represents people killed by
systematic or systemic racism
and barry is defiant and is refusing to
back away from what she did
and the white house is backing the
athlete
but i know he's incredibly proud to be
an american
and has great respect for the anthem and
all that it represents especially for
our men and women serving in uniform all
around the world
he would also say of course that part of
that pride in our country
means recognizing there are moments
where we are as a country haven't lived
up to our highest ideals
and it means respecting the right of
people granted to them in the
constitution to peacefully protest
so jessie the question from peter ducey
was not about whether she had the right
to do what she did it was whether it was
appropriate given her position as
someone who wants to represent
team usa at the olympics what is the
difference
they call that a layup right dana she
tried to both sides disrespecting
the anthem if i was on the committee for
the olympic squad i would sanction her
not from
for the display of disrespect i would do
it for poor sportsmanship
she was third right right yeah the other
two women who had the gold and the
silver that was their moment
and that was the country's moment to
reflect on a great
event and instead she poisoned the
chemistry of the female track and
field squad and she made it all about
herself she drew
attention from them and from the country
to herself and it was negative attention
no one's talking about systemic racism
after we see this
we are talking about her right and the
disrespect and the
probable i don't think she knows that
much about
what she was doing up there she doesn't
have a long
record of um of writings with regard to
systemic racism in this country
it was a symbolic act that was vacuous
in my opinion
hammer throwing is a beautiful sport it
is i dialed in on youtube today gut felt
and i was there for at least 40 minutes
it is graceful there's power there's
precision and timing
and she just took it from a positive and
made it a negative if this country is so
racist
why do you want to represent a racist
country to the world
yeah and why do you want to reap the
benefits of this racist country
and then get up there place third and
then spit in our face
she can throw hammers i'll change the
channel click
when she's on ever again and i think the
rest of the country feels the same way
it's just another event that liberals
ruin
well i'm really glad that you mentioned
the winner and the second place the
winner was dan
deanna price and the second place
finisher was brooke anderson because
they did get that taken away from them
dana well so deanna price actually
destroyed the hammer throw record
yeah and she should be our lead i'm so
excited because
i don't know if you've seen any of the
olympic trials our athletes are really
good
and america is going to kick some rear
end watch your mouth young lady the best
thing about the olympics like
i'll watch america against anyone like
i'll even watch table tennis
if america is going to beat france and
table tennis i am totally there for that
i watch hammer throwing deanna price
deserves a lot more attention there are
so many patriotic athletes
that are out there and some of these
young people that are you know athletes
if they're going to take a stand and
exercise their right fine
but then you know everyone else has a
right to react
and have their own feelings about it
harold i think that's the big question
if she wants to represent team usa
ironically in beijing which is part of a
communist country that is you know
engaged in genocide against people
who for generations has sterilized women
and forced them only to have one
one child i mean this idea that she is
signing up for a job
to represent the united states but
doesn't want to be on the podium when
the national anthem for the country
plays i think that's what's difficult
for people to really
come to terms with and accept given it's
she's signing up for that role
no doubt about it she didn't i don't
think she announced her support for
china so i i hear you and i hope she
doesn't go over there i don't suspect
she will do that
you know i've always been taught to
honor the flag of the anthem and i do
and i have um but dissent can co-exist
in
in a country and we still expound our
patriotism and honor the symbols of our
society
we shouldn't assassinate someone's
character because we disagree with them
that's what cancer culture does they try
to censor people now i do think you
raise a legitimate question around
do you feel strongly enough about the
country to go and represent us
uh in the olympics and i think that's
the question i'd love to hear her answer
i have no issue with her saying that i
want the country to live up more to
all the country promises to beat every
citizen we're striving every day to be a
more perfect union
but i do think that's the one question
uh that perhaps this athlete will have
to answer
and if the olympics wants every athlete
to stand during all of this and to not
buy they should make that a rule
and it's my understanding when you're
when you are throwing a hammer they
don't ask you what your position is in a
national anthem they want to see how far
you can throw that thing so if she can
win a medal
you know we'll probably won't fill this
room i would also ask them about their
age
like how good is your aim because where
am i standing when the hammer is being
thrown
that's a good question dana i'm going to
watch it from the television
when she put that t-shirt on that says
activist athlete she's replacing her
uniform
which she's trying to the universe is
going to wear if she makes it is going
to be
you know the usa and so she's making it
all about herself rather than about the
team which
that's not what teamwork is about makes
you wonder who the real tool is
we'll be right back hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else